c'est un moment décisif pour le
nucléaire français d'ici les cinq
prochaines années plus de la moitié des
réacteurs auront atteint le seuil des 40
années d'exploitation
leur durée de vie pourrait être prolongé
mais dans un avenir proche un dilemme se
pose faut-il continuer à compter sur le
nucléaire et donc construire de
nouvelles centrales ou compter sur le
développement des énergies renouvelables
nucléaire stop ou encore on tente d'y
voir plus clair dans facture
[Musique]
d'abord faisons un petit état des lieux
du mix électrique français 70 % de notre
électricité provient du nucléaire les
énergies renouvelables en produisent un
peu plus de 21 % et les énergies
thermiques fossiles environ 8%
c'est ici dans cet immense parc occupe
le nucléaire que se situe l'enjeu ce
sont 4 100 térawattheures de production
d'électricité par an il va falloir
remplacer mais par quoi rte le réseau de
transport d'électricité a publié un
dernier rapport avec l'agencé
internationale de l'énergie
dans celui-ci il étudie plusieurs
scénarios dont la possibilité d'un
réseau électrique 100 % renouvelable
d'ici 2050
c'est la première hypothèse la fin du
nucléaire est contrainte il faut prévoir
une augmentation de la consommation
d'électricité en 2050 nous en
consommeront 630 térawattheures selon
rte soit 33% de plus aujourd'hui nous
devons cela aux nouveaux usages de
l'électricité comme le développement des
voitures électriques par exemple
aujourd'hui voici ce que représente le
solaire et l'éolien en production et
pour pouvoir se passer du nucléaire
voici les capacités qu'il faudrait selon
les différents scénarios soit au moins
dix fois plus d'éolien et de solaire
c'est certain que ça nécessiterait les
rythmes d'installation en éolien en
panneaux solaires qui sont élevées
notamment très élevé par rapport à la
france
on est sur des rythmes qui correspondent
à ce que l'on a pu voir ou ce que l'on
peut encore voir aujourd'hui dans
certains pays européens développés à
100% ces énergies demande de relever
plusieurs défis techniques pour assurer
la sécurité d'approvisionnement
c'est à dire de pouvoir être sûr que
tout le monde bénéficie d'électricité
évitez tomber dans le noir problème la
plupart de ces énergies fonctionne par
intermittence le vent ne souffle pas
tout le temps et le soleil ne brille pas
toute la journée
une solution serait de pouvoir stocker
cette électricité pour pouvoir
l'utiliser quand on le souhaite sur ces
questions-là développer du stockage dans
les solutions elles existent aujourd'hui
les batteries ça existe donc on sait le
faire transformer de l'électricité en
hydrogène est possible a ensuite
transformé cet hydrogène à un moment en
électricité c'est des choses qui sont
qui semble qu'ils sont potables
autre défi à relever la flexibilité des
usages le terme est barbare joue la
corde mais l'explication est simple
il faudrait que l'on consomme autant que
l'on produit et si vous avez bien suivi
lors d'une nuit sans gants on ne produit
pas beaucoup avec du sang pour sang
renouvelables et ça ça peut nous pousser
à revoir nos modes de consommation
quand vous commencez à chercher sur les
30 qui arrondit à watts de consommation
à déplacer ça commence ça va commencer
un petit peu agrandie en si on commence
à vous dire bah la paix celle vous
pouvez pas le faire trop et maintenant
la télé c'est pas maintenant qu'il faut
l'allumer la cuisson ce sera plutôt à
22h et pas à 19 heures ça peut commencer
à avoir un vrai impact
un pack tout seul on ne se dit pas que
les trains ne pourront pas fonctionner
quand il ya pas de vent on se dit que
par contre une partie des usages
domestiques
j'ai par la recherche des chauffe-eau ça
pourrait être la recharge des véhicules
électriques pourraient être déplacées en
fonction de l'état du système et dans la
mesure où ça ne perturbe pas la vie la
vie des citoyens
autre possibilité et si nous décidions
de continuer avec du nucléaire
c'est la deuxième hypothèse construire
de nouvelles centrales
cette option semble d'ailleurs
privilégiée par le président de la
république notre avenir énergétique et
écologique passe par le nucléaire
car le principal avantage du nucléaire
c'est de pouvoir fournir de
l'électricité constamment et en grande
quantité combien de centrales
faudrait-il alors construire essayons
d'y voir plus clair
autant vous le dire tout de suite cela
dépend de beaucoup de facteurs est
difficile d'avoir une réponse précise la
durée de vie maximale d'une centrale est
de 60 ans partons sur cette fourchette
côte
nous disposons de 18 sites comptant au
total 56 rect d'ici 2050
il n'en resterait plus que 9 d'une durée
de vie de 1 à 12 ans attention rien ne
dit que certaines ne fermeront pas havre
on peut aussi ajouter le troisième
réacteur de flamanville qui n'est pas
encore en service
voici le paysage plutôt abstrait de la
production nucléaire en france sans
construire quelle que soit la puissance
encore disponibles de ses réacteurs
il faudrait plus de neuf fois ce que
produisait la centrale de civaux en 2019
pour avoir 25% de nucléaire et plus de
14 fois pour obtenir 50%
si vous projetez en 2050 vous êtes entre
entre 20 il 30
repères à construire d'ici là pour
maintenir 50% de nucléaire dans le mix
électrique mais construire des centrales
n'est pas vraiment simple
en 2007 on débute la construction du
troisième réacteur de flamanville avec
une mise en fonctionnement prévus pour
2012 pour plusieurs raisons dont des
anomalies détectées
elle est maintenant prévu pour 2023 de
quoi inquiéter dans l'hypothèse de
construire d'autres règles on a perdu
énormément de compétences dans le
domaine de la construction nucléaire
c'est vrai en france c'est vrai dans le
monde occidental
on voit bien qu'ils filières entières à
reconstruire
c'est aussi pour ça que edf veut lancer
maintenant 1
des constructions lutter c'est qu'il va
qui disent on a déjà essuyé pas mal de
plâtre avec flamanville c'est pas le
moment d'attendre cinq ans pour dans 5
ans relancer des rectangulaire et se re
dire qu'on a encore perdu du savoir
faire passons à l'addition combien
coûtent ces deux hypothèses pour la
théorie du 100% renouvelable
on ne sait pas mais cher dans son
rapport
rte souligne que les coûts seront
importants le rapport rte il ne
il ne chiffre pas les scénarios cette
étape est celle que nous rendrons à
l'automne dans des scénarios y aura une
autre portion d'énergies renouvelables
il ya une opposante du coût non
négligeable qui lie à la flexibilité et
c'est bien ça qu'on va essayer de le
quantifier maintenant pour donner un
ordre d'idée selon la cour des comptes
les engagements pris en faveur des
énergies renouvelables jusqu'à 2017
représente 121 milliards d'euros autour
du nucléaire maintenant là encore pas de
chiffres précis c'est assez difficile à
déterminer
donc le suivant pour financier votre
nucléaire avec
de la tête d'edf et des fonds propres de
dfc y ait un financement d'état le coup
d un seul pan pas le même prenons tout
de même l'exemple du troisième réacteur
de flamanville
son coût initial était prévue à 3
milliards d'euros il est aujourd'hui
estimée à 19 milliards par la cour des
comptes
une fois ces deux hypothèses posées un
facteur de poids vient s'ajouter
c'est le facteur écologique pour
répondre à ces objectifs climatiques
la france doit atteindre la neutralité
carbone en 2050 est divisé par six ses
émissions de gaz à effet de serre
et contrairement à ce que l'on pourrait
penser comme les énergies renouvelables
le nucléaire n'émet quasiment pas de co2
et est une énergie dite décarbonée on
peut le voir sur cette carte
grâce à sa grande capacité de production
nucléaire la france fait figure de bon
élève cocorico avec le renouvelable en
complément la france à une électricité
décarbonés à 93% alors aujourd'hui et ce
qui paraît important de tirer un trait
sur complet sur le nucléaire
je pense que ce serait une erreur
je pense qu'on peut compter sur lui
claire pour décarbonés partie des
systèmes énergétiques
suite
il faut de clermont aura besoin des deux
et à l'échelle mondiale c'est clairement
plus les randoulats qui sont 33 culte
quoi qu'il en soit le gouvernement a
repoussé sa décision sur la stratégie
adoptée construire à ton de nouvelles
centrales nucléaires
la réponse au prochain quinquennat
[Musique]